[Musique]
je m'appelle lisa je suis artiste
peintre et je suis allergique à la
peinture ce qui m'a sauvé je dois à
présent mon protégé
je suis franco libanaise quand on est
enfant dans les années 80 ça signifie
être envahi en permanence par des images
de la guerre du liban avec les attentats
il est mort la peur à l'âge les autres
enfants on pense à s'amuser
moi je pensais surtout à ma famille
restée là bas ça fait grandir plus vite
et puis un jour j'ai dit stop stop à
cette inquiétude sourde 1,7 ce mal être
permanent
j'ai décidé que je pouvais tout le temps
être positive
un vrai choix mais ce n'est pas facile
j'avais besoin de l'aide j'avais besoin
d'un échappatoire et c'est l'art par le
dessin et la peinture qui m'a offert mon
antidote à cette inquiétude qui me
rongeait je me suis créé mon monde à
l'abri une bulle protégée du monde
extérieur que j'ai rempli de mes
personnages joyeux doute très
accueillants et un peu fou comme dans
alice au pays des merveilles mais sans
la méchante reine
je n'avais plus peur je n'étais plus
seule l'ars a eu pour moi cette vertu
première de m'apaiser de me rassurer de
me reconnecter à des émotions positives
et joyeuse elle connaît quand on est
enfant oui l'art fait du bien pour un
artiste
la création est un mode d'expression
comme ce n'est pas forcément une très
bonne idée d'aborder des inconnus dans
la rue en souriant et que j'aime moi
véhicules et mon enthousiasme et ma joie
de vivre et de belles choses positives
comme ça j'ai préféré mettre mes
sourires sur une toile et au fur et à
mesure que je m'épanouisse et je
m'envoie zone est alors au début les
symptômes n'était pas vraiment méchant
c'était comme quand on a un peu abusé
des mojitos voyez le truc les jambes
flageolent un peu la tête tourne
rien de vraiment méchant et puis
rapidement ce devenu beaucoup moins
drôle quand je commençais à manquer
d'air à m'étouffer et âme évanouir et là
il fallait agir vite il fallait vraiment
faire vite on enclenche une batterie de
tests et rapidement le verdict tombe
lapidaire l'institut pasteur désormais
mme interdit formellement de m'approcher
tout ce qui peut m'être fatal je suis
devenue intolérante à la peinture
on ne peut rien y faire ça ne se soigne
pas ma première réaction a été comment
vous dire non ben non vous vous vous
pouvez pas dire un truc pareil je peux
pas vous avez pas compris la les
couleurs c'est ma vie je ne peux pas
j'ai donc passé une période un peu
compliquée et puis le naturel revient au
galop et je décide à nouveau qu'il ya
forcément une solution
forcément donc je cherche et je trouve
maintenant je travaille dans un
container aménagé dans une cabine de
peinture de carrosserie ventilés en
permanence donc avec mon masque et avec
cet air renouveler en permanence je ne
risque presque plus rien bon je vous
cache pas qu'en ce moment il y fait un
froid polaire il je travaillais avec une
tenue de trappeur du grand nord et c'est
pas grave c'est pas grave parce que tout
simplement si je prends ce risque c'est
que je n'ai pas de choix pour moi les
couleurs c'est mon vocabulaire mon
alphabet ma façon d'être de vivre je
vois le monde à travers mes couleurs
je veux le monde et je l'entends
oui j'ai un processus de création un peu
particulier
je suis synesthète mots un peu étrange
pour dire tout simplement que je mélange
les sens
alors pour certains ça va être voir les
chiffres en couleurs pour d'autres c'est
une image qui va leur évoqué un goût
pour moi ça passe par la musique
quand j'entends de la musique je vois
des coupes des formes des nuances de
couleurs bizarres un bon il faut que je
vous montre
allez si j'entends ça
[Musique]
je vois cela je vois ça est ce que vous
voyez le côté pétillant joyeux
enthousiaste et explosive de la musique
on a entendu ça vous parle
avec les volutes de couleur vous y êtes
pas tout à fait ok on va faire un autre
exemple alors maintenant si j'entends ça
ça vous parle plus ces morceaux de
musique électro j'aime beaucoup et pour
moi est ce que vous voyez à l'arrière
prend l'arrière-plan pardon les basses
que je vois avec les taches de couleurs
froides et à l'avant pour moi ce sont
les fils les clés les phrases musicales
qui sont et qui sont sur le devant
vous voyez ça vous parle un peu plus
bombée ça y est vous êtes dans ma tête
bienvenue on pourrait en rester là et se
dire ne regarder que l'aspect décoratif
d'une toile regardez les couleurs se
dire par exemple vient ce bleu est pas
mal et pourrait très bien aller avec
canapé du salon
ça pourrait être une idée simple
réducteur parce que en général les
artistes nous on aime bien la décence
caché qui est une deuxième vision que ce
qui est quelque chose qui demande un
petit effort pour essayer de comprendre
ce cas derrière par exemple pour moi
cette toile je les appelais amour love
c'est pour ça que vous avez du bleu vous
avez du rose mais c'est pas seulement
sont honnêtes et de couleurs pour moi
c'est vraiment l'évolution d'une
relation amoureuse avec le côté très
pétillant un petit peu chaotique aussi
un qui a forcément début une relation on
est d'accord très passionné et puis
derrière les couleurs qui se mélangent
tendrement avec vous voyez une accession
à la pureté avec le dos de la toile
beaucoup plus clair voilà pour moi ça
c'est l'amour ans à l'art est un
formidable antidote à l'indifférence
parce qu'ils possèdent curieux à essayer
de comprendre ce cas derrière à essayer
de comprendre ce que l'artiste a voulu
dire à essayer de comprendre l'autre à
chercher justement ce fameux sens caché
ans à l'art ouvre l'esprit
comme je voulais dit j'aime à mélanger
les bulles artistique et quand les la
musique rencontre mes couleurs
cela peut aussi donner vie à des projets
comme celui-ci on m'a confié la création
du prototype d'un des prochains mtv
awards
alors oui forcément je suis très fier de
ce projet s'est permis des beaux projets
qui me porte
merci c'est pas encore fait mais on
croise les doigts
c'est parmi des beaux projets qui me
porte
mais très honnêtement c'est pas de ça
dont je suis le plus fier ce qui me rend
le plus fier c'est quand je reçois des
messages comme celui d'hélène que j'ai
vous lire votre tableau irradie de
lumière d'énergie et de douceur c'est
une oeuvre vivante joyeuse qui me donne
envie de vivre
quand j'ai lu ces mots j'ai su à ce
moment là que si larmes avaient sauvé
j'avais à mon tour ce même pouvoir grâce
à mes couleurs d'apporter du bon du
mieux du bien autour de moi dans ma
famille il y as nous avons une devise
qui remontent à l'époque de la
renaissance donc en latin joue la
traduire ces facs benes père a fait le
bien ou du bien et espère voilà la
boucle est bouclée
je suis enfin à ma place dans ce monde
oui l'arf du bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]